box that you could put those in so then for sure your questions will go on. I do have the chat
available. Last week I apologize that some questions that came in I think of the YouTube chat
I wasn't able to see so maybe that's a little forward those to me so we got several questions that
came in and I want to answer a couple from last week that I must not able to see. So first of all
first question my teenage son has a lot of pain in his feet when he's been on them for an extended
period of time he wears compression socks and has custom orthotics he's seen a diatrist
pediatric rheumatoid doctor MRI shows inflammation in his feet so I think you're doing the right thing
as far as looking for the source of inflammation does this person have too but I don't have
a rheumatoid you're always digging to the reason why so it could be something as simple as
falling arches the arch support when I was in in high school I got fitted with these leather type
arch support which I think the hard arch supports are not good I think you need a compressible
arch support I think it was a foot levelers brain leather arch support and boy that made a
giant difference in my inflammation in my feet I was an athlete and you know we just put a lot of
pressure on my feet as you get older you have foot pain because you know you have other things going
on but as a as a young adult you should not there's there's a reason why you got to let you have
that sort of foot pain if you feel like you have to wear some sort of compression socks or something
so digging in to find out what that could be looking for autoimmune issues rheumatoid arthritis
goalie arthritis different things like that you just got to keep digging tell you figure that out
I can't really give you a whole lot more information without you know seed you know more details on
this history I wish I could now there's just too many possibilities just with that data next question
I was using a glutathione supplement in coffee enemas before I got diagnosed cancer is it possible
that glutathione caused my cancer I have been sugar and grain free for 20 years also totally
organic diet for 40 years and keto low carb diet with consistency daily fasting can glutathione
cause cancer well for most people who don't understand that connection that would be culture intuitive
glutathione is an antioxidant glutathione helps prevent cancer because most cancers are
caused from some sort of toxin or oxidizing agent that's getting inside the cell and damaging
the nucleus so remember cancer is a cell that you know something got inside that cell and damaged
the nucleus so the nucleus is now in a state of rapid replication that's what the definition
of cancer is and it's replicated cells that are in a state of replication now the reason why this
person asked about glutathione and cancer is that I am one of those doctors who advocates against
using glutathione once a person has a diagnosis of cancer and the reason why I would say glutathione is
culture contradictory for a person with cancer diagnosis is that cancer cells because they're already
rapidly replicated are already producing a lot of oxidative stress so they're at that
dear lethal dose of oxidative stress and by using glutathione which is an antioxidant you're
basically helping to keep a cancer cell alive now I would not say that glutathione causes cancer so
answer this person question is it possible that using glutathione in my coffee animals before
my cancer diagnosis would be a cause of my cancer I would say absolutely not glutathione is something
that I would recommend somebody who knows they do not have a diagnosis cancer we are exposed to
oxidizing agents you know at a rate that is maybe a hundred times greater than our ancestors and
we need support for glutathione glutathione is your main interest cellular antioxidant it's helping
get rid of those those damaging reactive oxygen and reactive nitrogen species that develop
in the presence of both pathogens developing that our body and in the presence of
of toxic chemical toxins so using glutathione helps decrease the chance of a person getting cancer
but however once you have cancer you could actually be helping the cancer stay alive so what's if you
have a diagnosis of cancer then many of the treatments certainly standards of care treatment
chemotherapy is an oxidizing agent and it works to kill cancer because cancer cells
get a state of rapid replication are producing a lot more reactive oxygen species they're at a
state nearer a lethal dose of oxidation and have you given an extra little boost of oxidation
a chemotherapy you can tell to kill the cancer so that's why cancer cells
die first with chemotherapy chemotherapy can damage other cells though that's the negative of it
but cancer cells are nearer their lethal dose of oxidative stress already so giving them a little
more oxidative stress will help kill cancer cells so I wouldn't use glutathione once you have
cancer but certainly it's not a cause of cancer okay next question what to do when you have a
conflicting genetic defect that is CONT defects with MTRR defects CONT genes help produce multiple
things but they function in the myopterid pathway and they help with the neurotransmitter function
the MTR or the MTRR genes are in the vitamin B12 corbolamine pathway in the natiety pathway
for one you should take hydroxyl comolamine and the other methyl comolamine thanks
well first of all you don't I don't treat G genetic defects you don't go okay you have
a CONT gene defects so you should be this or you should you have a MTRR should have to be
on this you have to look at it as a big picture of everything else that's going on with that patient
so genetic your genetic picture is just one piece of that puzzle you'd I would be careful with
methyl comolamine with anybody because if you have a lot of other defects in the myopterid pathway
you excess methyl groups are going to push that pathway and it's very common that person ends up
with excess serotonin because they were diagnosed some doctor did a genetic test of them
they had MTR or MTRR gene defects or they had MTHFR defects your methyl tetrahedral folate gene
and then they were given a methyl folate or methyl comolamine thinking that oh well you have
an issue with decreased methylation so you need to be out of methyl sudden methyl groups they're
given those methyl groups without really looking at the the patient's big picture where are there
there to our transmitters at are there other defects in the myopterid pathway that would suggest
that excess methyl groups would be not a good idea it's I see that quite commonly so that these
people are given methyl groups because oh my goodness you have a MTHFR defects so you need methyl groups
no you don't so that's not the way to care for somebody is to treat them for a genetic standpoint
alone you have to look at the big picture furthermore person has a perfect example as a person has
a diagnosis of cancer and you're giving them methyl groups one of the things methyl groups do is
they silence genes they turn off genes and excess methyl groups could turn off tumor suppressor
genes because so if a person does have cancer you are dependent upon your tumor suppressor genes
to stimulate the intrinsic apoptotic pathway to kill cancer cells and if you're taking excess
methyl groups you're basically silencing that pathway you could turn off that pathway so I don't
if a person has cancer I don't want them on any methyl groups unless a bigger picture tells us to do so
they have issues with home assisted or something like that I don't put them on methyl groups for a
period of time so again you don't just treat one thing you don't look at even one lab and
only and treat based upon that mud lab you got to look at the patient's big picture what is there
other diagnoses what are there other issues what are there other lab findings so
cancer question I don't just treat you don't treat a genetic defect you have to look at the big picture
next question my son has a rare autoimmune disorder pioderma
um uh gay gay gruesome he has been under care of a team of doctors in St. Louis University
high-dose predisone almost killed him they wanted him an immunosuppressants
let's stop right there so yes if a person has an autoimmune disease from a medical standpoint
especially if they're an acute player they're going to put them on an anti-inflammatory immunosuppressant
because an autoimmune disease when it's in it's acute fare flare is in a hyper-th-1 response
so predisone steroid is going to calm that down um problem is people could react um
apparently to steroid so in this case it was a grave aberrant reaction to predisone that this
person said almost killed him they want him an immunosuppressants that would be the medical treatment
for an autoimmune disease try to suppress the immune system um we do not want to go this route where
using holistic plant-based treatments but need more help it's terrified he's only 37 it needs his
life back thank you in advance so first of all that's the medical route how to treat an autoimmune
disease is to use immune um suppressants it actually will in many cases decrease the person's
symptoms problem is it does nothing to address the problem so um I'm going to highly recommend
anybody with an autoimmune disease at this person if they're listening to their question being
answered um to go enjoy our chronic disease at autoimmune course because I go into um you know
great detail about what to do with an autoimmune disease first of all so an autoimmune disease
when your body starts making antibodies against its own tissue if you're starting to make antibodies
against uh cells in the skin or the subcutaneous later layer of the skin that's a type of autoimmune
disease that is a pio-derma autoimmune disease so rare disease I had to look it up what I saw this
question it creates boils and stuff on the skin and um it's it's you can create antibodies to any
tissue any any tissue any cell line at your body and that's what an autoimmune disease is
why is it there so first of all um that's a good thing to look for does the person have
some sort of toxicity heavy metal toxicity that cause the body to end up creating antibodies
again self tissue many times when a either a um toxin or a biotoxin is in the body and it goes
intracellular inside the cell the immune system is going to fire to try to kill it
apparently if it's a toxin because a toxin can't die um normally if it's a biotoxin because that's
what the immune system is supposed to do is kill biotoxin but if it goes inside the cell your immune
system can't kill it and if it's firing at a th1 th2 response multiple times the th2 responses
the b cell response that then creates antibodies it's supposed to create antibodies against the
infection let's say strap or something like that but if this thing keeps going inside the cell
or if this toxin is inside the cell an immune system is apparently seeing a toxin as something
it needs to kill it could create antibodies to that cell line where it's found so find it out what
the cause of this is can be helpful because you could help detox that it help calm that down
more importantly it's you have to find out what the person's triggers are so anything that
will trigger an immune response is going to make the damage to whatever tissue that that person
has antibodies against aka the type of autoimmune disease it's going to cause that to flare so
person says I have this pyodermal autoimmune disease and it keeps flaring and it's so bad it's
you got to find out what other triggers are stimulating the person's immune response or you're
just going to go a medical route you're just going to do an immune suppressive that's just to me that
will help in an acute situation but that's not the wrong term way to treat an autoimmune disease
you have to find out the cause you have to find out what the triggers are there's ways to test for
this and I go into exhausting detail on that course so if you don't test for and find out what your triggers
are you are you are just committed to just having you know just constant flares of this disease
in and a horrible light you can find out what those triggers are you can calm those down wherever
this is I've been patients with MS antibodies to my legit cells if you find out what your triggers
are you can calm down that immune response then you can work out on some natural anti-inflammatory
things and you can really help get that person's life back on your control now this person says we
are doing a holistic plant-based treatments why would caution you highly that you know what are
those holistic plant-based treatments if you're doing herbals that are stimulated in immune
response you're making the person worse so if you're doing any type of natural care
with an autoimmune disease that is that is stimulated in immune response you're making the person
worse perfect examples person like I have chronic Lyme but it's really not chronic Lyme it's they have
autoimmune disease now and that's what their symptoms are and they keep taking you know cats claw
or some immune stimulant now I'm taking this now I'm doing this a straggolous protocol for Lyme
this is just absolutely the wrong thing to do you can't be doing immune stimulants when you have
self-antibodies you know I've said this a million times once you have self-antibodies and you
stimulate the immune response for from any source you are going to kill that what you have antibodies
against cell that means you're going to kill cell tissue you're going to cause a flare so take
vitamin C it's immune stimulant you're going to cause a flare you take garlic it's immune stimulant
you're going to cause a flare you take a straggolous you take echinacea you're going to cause a flare
well I'm trying to kill the bacteria or I'm trying to kill the Lyme but try to kill this or my
by natural doctor said to do this a lot of doctors whether they're natural or not natural doctors
don't understand an autoimmune disease so highly suggest you take that course we have doctors
taking that course 50 bucks that will help you'll learn something it's set up a case review with
me if you want to through the course or through our website okay next question what can I do
to help with high cholesterol my doctor wants me to go on statins so so depending on what you
what you define high cholesterol so when I graduated from school 220 and above
I think it was 220 and above was considered high then they dropped it out to 200 and above was considered
high now I think it's eight 180 and above was considered high why because they can sell more
statins I'm sorry but that sounds really neat but it's true so that's the reason why they do it high
cholesterol by itself is not you know it's going to be arterial damaging it's when you have
when you have high cholesterol with damage or etched arteries that the arteries are going to be
complex with that cholesterol always with high cholesterol you always want to find out why now there's
some people with high cholesterol that have a familial congenital condition of hyper cholesterol
that no matter what you do you would take your statins you're not going to really get that
be close to normal ranges and there are some people with cholesterol over 300 that have had
cholesterol over 300 that have no no familial condition of high cholesterol and they you know they're
in their 60s or 70s and they've had this their whole life and have had scans of their heart and have
no cholesterol factor well what's the what's the deal with that because it's not high cholesterol
alone that causes arterial sclerosis it is high cholesterol with with inflammatory condition tied to
the endothelial cells which are the cells that line the arteries so endothelial condition is what
is really causing the problems not the high cholesterol by itself now I have people with cholesterol of
225 and their doctor is putting heavy pressure on them to go on statins well you need to educate
yourself in quite back against that I would not do that but again you don't just look at cholesterol
so again you don't just look at one test plus you should break down the cholesterol so if you're
going to do a proper blood test for inflammatory markers that are tied to fats and tied to
inflammation in the endothelial cells you need to break down the cholesterol into the different
densities of LDLs and oxidized LDLs and you need to do a more comprehensive blood test before you
start thinking about going on stats I'm not against using medications when it's the right thing to do
but I've used I'm very against using medications just to alter a blood test because a person can have
low cholesterol tell you my dad was a perfect example of that he had low cholesterol and had a heart
attack had a triple bypass surgery well that happened he has low cholesterol because cholesterol is not
the issue you know it's that is not the problem it's inflammation of the endocardial tissue
and the most common causes of endocardial endothelial inflammation is H. Pylori chronic
Lyme heavy metal toxicity there's a couple other ones but you got to dig into that and find that
source of that so very very important next question my dad has sepsis close call
but back at home tons way too many in my opinion of antibiotics he has irritatory tract infection
that he can't get rid of along with a catheter still he's been it's been over a month now we
you what would you recommend for from your clinic thanks so much have a blessed day okay so a person
with irritatory tract infection sepsis that's an infection that's carried in the blood
that can be deadly what do you do okay just I mean it's like what's your protocol for this well
you got to dig to figure out what this is first of all did they do they test the blood did they do
a culture did they find out what the infection was did they do a culture of a year there a year in
culture to see what the infection in the irritatory tract is because that's dependent how you would
actually treat it if he's been a ton of antibiotics then maybe it's not a bacteria or it was the
wrong antibiotic for the bacteria for they didn't culture if I don't what the bacteria is to
if I don't what the antibiotics should be again we see this all the time just had a conversation
with gentlemen that had blood work done in May or in March had elevated white blood cell count
definitely to the level where he had a corrected infection elevated neutrophils which would suggest
most likely a bacterial infection and I did know where the labs his VA doctor did
ordered those labs didn't do anything about it didn't tell him that there was an infection didn't
tell him that we needed to treat it and then went back in again at the end of April they didn't
even re-run the labs I just don't get it why do you run the labs if you don't do anything with them
especially when there's positive findings and you do nothing with them why did you run the labs
again or you put this person on some type of protocol and then you don't retest to see if you
actually fixed it I'm sorry I'm just at a loss for words here these medical doctors have these
multi billion dollar complexes where they can run CTs MRIs blood work at you know within a couple
hours get the results back and then they don't either don't read them don't know how to read them don't
do anything with them don't retest I'm sorry I'm a little frustration wagon here because I don't
have those wonderful tools at my disposal where I could get blood work back within a couple hours
and try to help the patient and they do and they don't do anything with them so from a general
nutritional standpoint without no weed anymore data I could help this person if a person has
a urinary tract infection that doesn't go away if they have an infection in their bladder
one product that we use in our office is an herbal product called borosma complex because it has
couch grass in it has licorice in it has echinacea in it and butchoo in it which is really good for
the urinary tract another product would be de mantles which is a sugar that actually is really good
for UTIs that's I'm not telling you to take that those would just be things that would be general
recommendations with UTIs okay one of the questions I've just came in Dr. Cutters I'm 67 year old female
I was diagnosed with a large bladder I have no pain they did diagnostic testing and just determined
I do not have urine retention they told me I must have had urine retention in the past my bladder
size is greater than 1000 milliliters I went to an alternative doctor he suggested it was estrogen
dominance he wants me to apply table spoon of progestE brand name every night for two weeks
out of the month the theory is that if I apply it every day of the month my liver will start
canceling it out what do you think and what would you do in my case I take thyroid meds but I'm
otherwise healthy so I don't know if this alternative doctor is just following a protocol that they've
used in the past that they've had success within the past I don't know that in order to find out if
you have estrogen dominance you should test a dodge test is probably the best test on the market
dodge test is a dry urine hormone test and they test for you know all the estrogen
metabolites and progesterone and antigen metabolites as well and you can see if you have estrogen
dominance or not also test for cortisol levels so ordering the dodge test I think would be the
right thing to do so and then you'll know is there any harm in taking progesterone that's what that
product I believe is it's a topical progesterone is there any harm in taking that probably not
so if you have confidence in that doctor in the way that that doctor he or she tested or I don't
think that there's necessarily any harm in doing that when somebody your age most people have
low progesterone at 67 years old I don't think there's a harm in doing that but I do think it's wise
to get tested so if that doctor will test you can order tests if you're a course member I don't
know if this person is one of our course members but if you are on our chronic disease autoimmune
course or any of our other courses you can run the labs through them and it would be the
Dutch complete test that I would recommend okay so remember to go to the holistichelpour.com if you
want to post a question you can post a question on the chat as well a couple other questions
from a few weeks ago that I was not able to get to what is why do so many people say to drink
apple cider vinegar I see so many posts on Instagram about apple cider vinegar what would be the rationale
okay so apple cider vinegar is a mild acid to see the acid so why would you take apple cider vinegar
well your stomach has to have a pH that's relatively very acidic so your stomach pH is at about
1.5 to 2.0 that's very acidic the acid that creates the acidic environment in the stomach is
hydrochloric acid produced by these cells in the stomach called as pridal cells at the stomach
and you need to have that level of acidity in your stomach for multiple reasons that's how you
break down proteins and carbohydrates in the stomach where you start the process of digestion that
is breaking down food into small particles so that you can absorb them that coupled with the
patellin that's secreted by your salivary gland HCl that's in the stomach combines in the dewandum
once that that bolus of food goes into the small intestine more partially digested combines in
the dewandum with the enzymes secreted from the pancreas and then combines with the bile which
helps break down fat and get rid of toxins from the gallbladder from the liver so you need an acidic
stomach and one could argue that the lack of acidity in your stomach mainly caused from a lack of
production of hydrochloric acid by the pridal cells mainly because of poor diet chemicals toxins
dyes, additives, colorings, flavorings, poisons, toxins, GMO foods etc. damaged those pridal cells so
you don't get enough production of HCl so then your stomach is relatively alkaline food is not getting
digested worst things happen you don't secrete intrinsic factor necessary for vitamin B12
absorption so that whole condition is called hypochloridria decrease hydrochloric acid in the stomach
that's what leads to leaky gut issues because you're not getting food properly digested broken down
putting a lot more stress on the pancreas one theory why the increase in pancreatic cancer exists
in the largement of pancreas, pancreas overall and pancreas tightest also it increases stress on the
liver and gallbladder so food is not getting broken down into its proper size molecules so proteins are
not getting broken down into die peptides or amino acids they go into the small intestine
into the larger intestine as larger peptides and can damage the gut walls along with all sorts of
toxins and GMO foods that you ate that damaged the gut wall now they can cross the gut border
as larger peptides you develop antibodies against different foods now you have food sensitivities
every time you eat those foods now you develop a inflammatory reaction of the gut that inflammatory
reaction the gut causes further degradation of the and epithelial layer of the gut damaging more
gut cells increasing the leaky gut issues it's just a giant ball of wax problem so you could solve
a lot of problems by taking HCl and digestive enzymes with each meal or if your stomach can't tolerate
that because you've had this damage for so long many times you also have an ulcer so you can't
even take HCl because it causes such very strong stabbing stomachache you can start with apple cider
vinegar and see if it sits a little bit milder acid and see if you can tolerate that if you can't
tolerate that you have to go back and just try to heal the gut heal the stomach with something like
deglycerized licorice now I have a blog post on this if you go to our website cuttersclinic.com
you'll see a blog post that goes through all the different steps about this
and just search hypochloridria or HCl hypochloridria something like that
search for HCl stomach issues and you'll find a blog post about this
this ties into the next question that says can I drink baking soda water to help alkalize
myself or have had people since our clinic mainly sees people with cancer maybe people say I'm
drinking high pH water thinking that's that's alkalizing yourself because they are holding to
a very incorrect theory that cancer can't grow in an acidic environment which is just completely
done physiological so cancer in itself because it's growing and it's a mass that's that's in rapid
replication is created in a acidic environment where it's growing and yes it'd be great to
alkalize that environment which don't alkalize that environment by drinking alkaline water or drinking
baking soda anybody that says that is just not understanding basic physiology these are the things
that hurt me about Instagram and Facebook and even that's quote unquote natural practitioners
that are making statements that are absurd that are just physiologically absurd so I hate to say
you know there's companies that sell you machines that give you high pH water there's people
that go with a store and you buy a water that's at 9.4 pH very alkaline all you're doing is alkalizing
your stomach you're completely counterattuitive does not make any sense whatsoever and you're physiologically
damaging your stomach your damaging your gut you're setting yourself up for all sorts of problems
thinking that you're doing something healthy I mean there's just there's a lot that the positive of
the internet is there's a lot of great stuff and you could basically get an education without leaving
your home the negative is there's a lot of wrong information and you can you can mislead yourself too
so you not understanding some basic physiology can be a problem and there was a question asked
a few weeks ago my my son or my daughter wants to go into naturopathic medicine natural medicine
what should I do what school would you push them towards there's some naturopathic type schools
that are online that are teaching information that is just completely wrong it's just it's sad it's
really sad and then people are graduating think that they should you know do things like this you know
they're telling people to drink alcohol and water they're telling people to drink baking soda water to
test their with pH strips test their saliva test their urine to see if they're alcohol or acidic it's
just total nonsense and it's it just gives natural doctors a bad name when you when when you see this
silliness that's out there that is worse than silliness because it could hurt people so I was kind of
at a loss I was kind of caught off hand with that with that question because I didn't know
how to how to point people to the right education to take now there are some good online courses and
online naturopathic schools and stuff to go to I just I can't think of any off the top my head
I'll talk to research at a little bit I would I would suggest take take our courses I mean
they're fifty bucks for our autoimmune course I just edit four videos today onto that course
and to modules three on that course that's going to take you several months to get through that you
know you'll you'll be smarter than most natural doctors by just going through that course I'm not
trying to pop myself up I've learned from people I'm standing at other people's shoulders you know I you
know and that's that's the you want to have a heart that's constantly learning that knows because
the more you really know the more you really know how much you don't know um and the more the more
you you you realize what you need to to learn um somebody just text me it's um the one naturopathic
school is Eden school um natural new Eden school for natural health that's it thank you guys
new Eden school for natural health I'd recommend that one that's a good one um but there's
another one trinity I would not recommend there's several online schools I would not recommend
there's a huge benefit to going like going through car practice school or going through a four-year
naturopathic school that is the you're going to learn physiology um but that's what you are not going
to learn through these online schools just because they don't have that that that hefty enough
of curriculum so we have had a couple of our practitioners the past did the new Eden school
and it's I think that's the best one that's out there right now oh but I did look at the trinity
and I was just very disappointed with that so um be careful of incorrect information you know if you
have questions about these things also remember to go to our website cutters clinic.com we have well
over a thousand blogs with a really good search engine then you can go to that search thing and
put in any question you want a pretty good chance that I've been video or dinner talk about it or
wrote an article about and if I did it ask the question out here so go to our holistichealthhour.com
website and ask a question okay I think um that is all the questions we have today we just do a double
check and so make sure you go to holistichealthhour.com also because all our posts our past holistic
health hours are indexed really nice. Dustin does a great job on that and um gives you topical
index so you can go to whatever class you want to listen to the whole thing and if you want to
make an appointment go to cutters clinic.com and you could schedule an appointment or call our office
to just ask questions. All right God bless you all and we'll see you next week bye.